je suis médaillé de bronze olympique et
recordwoman du monde et je suis très
très heureuse qu'une grande compétition
arrive en martinique
je dirige une association qui s'appelle
coco andlau et on sensibilise les
enfants à l'impact de la pollution sur
l'environnement à la connaissance du
milieu marin à travers l'apprentissage
de la natation donc c'est à travers les
valeurs de protection des océans qu'on
sera présent au village d'arrivée de la
transat jacques vabre
c'est pour expliquer comment un des
chefs qui est sur terre arrivent en mer
quel est son parcours est expliqué que
absolument tous les écosystèmes sont
touchés si un déchet se retrouvent dans
la nature
je trouve que c'est bien de pouvoir
accueillir un grand événement comme ça
et de mettre l'accent autour de la
protection des océans est d'autant plus
que la martinique vient d'être élue
réserve mondiale de biosphère de
l'unesco donc c'est vraiment une super
belle mise en lumière et ça encourage
les initiatives positives qui peuvent
être créées